news daily from science mission early
life adversity increases the risk of
psychopathology in later life the
underlying mechanisms is unknown but
epigenetic variation represents a
possible candidate in humans although
there is evidence for DNA methylation
changes in the peripheral blood of
psychiatric patients a fundamental
question remains as to whether
epigenetic markers in the blood can
predict epigenetic changes occurring in
the brain researchers used in natira BPA
exposure as a model environmental
exposures shown to disturb neuro
development and exact long-term effects
on behavior in animals and humans
prenatal bapa induces lasting DNA
methylation changes in transcriptional
event region of the bdnf gene in the
hippocampus and blood of mice as well as
behavioral changes these changes are
consistent with billion of changes in
the cord blood of humans exposed to high
maternal bpa levels in utero this data
suggests billion of DNA methylation in
blood may be used as a predictor of the
in bdnf DNA methylation and gene
expression as well as behavioral
vulnerability induced by early life
environmentally exposure next
contribution of each bacterium in the
microbiome is difficult to assess due to
lack of tools to distinguish them
scientist show that antimicrobial
peptide c 16 g to selectively killed the
pathogen streptococcus mutans which is
known to cause tooth decay in the saliva
authors found increased abundance of
various other streptococcus species that
are highly prevalent in healthy oral
cavities to compensate for loss of step
mittens so c 16 g 2 may have therapeutic
potential to remove pathogenic
streptococcus mutans and help achieve a
healthy oral microbiome
for more news visitors at www science
mission com or science mission facebook
page thanks for watching